notre mode de vie met en péril l'avenir
de l'humanité
les scientifiques nous avertissent
depuis des années le sentiment d'urgence
semble tout juste commencé à s'installer
c'est un mouvement mondial on voit en
allemand on le voit en france également
les mobilisations prennent de l'ampleur
la science est tellement frappante est
clair que les gens ont compris le
message est un message qui est envoyé
depuis longtemps déjà je pense que c'est
la question d'urgence le gouvernement
doit immédiatement prendre des mesures
draconiennes pour que les choses
changent pour mon fils et pour les
générations à venir
samedi de gaspé à gatineau ils étaient
des milliers à marcher ou à se
rassembler dans plusieurs villes du
québec pour forcer les gouvernements à
agir
les politiciens acquis les manifestants
destiné le message était dans la foule
on a pris acte clairement le 1er octobre
de cette importante priorité est
aujourd'hui on passe aux actes
on marche avec vous le gouvernement qui
est là présentement doit s'engager doit
avoir un message très clair on est à
deux semaines la coop 24 on est à deux
semaines la rentrée parlementaire
l'idée de cette marche est ni de simples
citoyens un groupe d'amis de collègues
qui trouvait qu'on parlait pas assez
dans l'environnement pendant la campagne
électorale et qui ont décidé de bouger
depuis quelques jours plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes ont également
signé le pacte pour la transition
des engagements ont changé leurs
habitudes pour réduire leur impact sur
la planète parce que les derniers
rapports du giec nations-unies sur les
changements qui met c'est comme ça qu'on
est rendus là et je sens mois dans la
danse qu'on entend un espace de bruit de
fond
quand les gens sont de plus en plus
touchés mais les efforts individuels ne
seront pas suffisantes
la science nous dit que l'humanité sans
nous engager dans sa plus grande
bataille
le défi que certains n'arrivent pas
encore à prendre au sérieux
issue d'une chaîne marsolais radio
canada montréal